Speaker 1: Well, I told you yesterday that
we would be looking at this today.
The rehabilitation, for lack of a better term
of the Biden presidency that's happened over
a period of just 26 days is quite stunning.
Think back to 26 days, almost a month ago.
Gas prices were down a little bit, but not
really that much.
We had just gotten yet another higher inflation
report.
Joe Biden had had a significant lag time in
terms of major legislative accomplishments
during his presidency.
And many were saying, what is the game plan
here?
What is the justification for voting for Democrats
in November?
What's the justification for thinking it's
even remotely plausible that Joe Biden might
run for reelection in November or in November
of 2024, that is.
And you had a relatively strong, strong Trump
doing rallies, surging, searching, still with
quite a high favorability rating among Republicans.
And think about the last 26 days where we
have now seen a significant not yet explosive
but significant, very decided uptick in Joe
Biden's approval rating.
If you take a look at the numbers, you see
that the approval rating for Joe Biden bottomed
out right around July 20, July 21.
That was kind of the low point now closing
in on about a month ago.
And since then, it has been a decidedly positive
trend, not so much in terms of the numbers.
I mean, it's really just been a shift from
37 to 40.
But remember that these are averages among
many different polls and the direction is
clearly positive compared to past presidents.
You might remember that FiveThirtyEight has
this great tool where you can compare Joe
Biden's current approval rating to those of
past presidents at this point in time, I believe,
were 574 days into Joe Biden's presidency,
and it was below every single president dating
all the way back to Truman.
It's now not quite so bad if you compare it
to prior presidents.
Joe Biden's uptick is now putting himself
within striking distance of where Donald Trump
was at this point in his presidency.
If you look at Bill Clinton with just a couple
more points, Biden would now have an equivalent
approval rating to that of Bill Clinton at
this point in his presidency.
You look at Reagan basically the same.
That gap where Reagan was more popular at
this point in his presidency has essentially
been eliminated.
And Biden has almost caught up there of roughly
equal to Jimmy Carter and now above.
Harry Truman.
A very low approval rating at this point in
his presidency, only 33 and Joe Biden above
that.
So what is the reason for this change?
Well, it's a combination of things.
It's some good news for Joe Biden and really
just humiliating bad news for Republicans
and for Donald Trump.
If you look at the Biden side, the positive
side, Inflation Reduction Act, Pact Act, a
jobs report with more than twice the number
of new jobs created versus the expectation
a wage report wages up half of a percent in
July.
Inflation report inflation year over year
coming down for the 12 month period ending
on July 31st.
And yes, although admittedly controversial
among progressives, the strike that successfully
killed al Qaeda terrorist Ayman al-Zawahiri,
no due process of concern to many down on
the left.
We will talk about that on the Thursday show.
But as far as presidential accomplishments
tend to go, taking out a known terrorist on
the most wanted list, generally speaking,
is considered an accomplishment.
And I know everybody will get mad and everybody
emails me as is David.
How can you call that an accomplishment?
How could you gloat about that?
It might not even be legal.
I'm with you.
But as far as presidential accomplishments
are concerned, it certainly counts.
So Joe Biden doing significant, significantly
much to help himself.
And then also you look at what's happening
on the Republican side.
Donald Trump now under criminal investigation
for violating the Espionage Act among a number
of other different federal statutes.
His home, Mar-A-Lago, having a search warrant
served, tons of stuff taken.
We learned yesterday that Trump's former personal
lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, is now under criminal
investigation in Georgia.
We learned yesterday that Donald Trump's Trump
Organization, CFO Allen Weisselberg is getting
ready to take a guilty plea.
It's it's all very, very bad on the Trump
side.
So all of a sudden, you have the midterms
not looking so bad with Democrats now, not
by much, but slightly favored to take the
Senate.
Democrats still like.
To lose the house, but maybe by not very much,
and at least a reinvigorated Democratic electorate.
Now, what will actually happen in November?
And what is the viability of Trump and or
Biden to run in 2024?
Still unclear, but a dramatic, dramatic turnaround
from where things were certainly 60 days ago.
Oh, and gas prices, I forgot to mention gas
prices also yesterday or today, ending something
like a 65 consecutive day decline.
All of those things are good as far as the
presidency is concerned.
And yeah, I mean, listen, it's a reasonable
thing to make the case that actually higher
gas prices, in a sense, are good long term
because they encourage people to abandon gasoline
powered vehicles.
You're 100% correct, if that's your view.
But the narrative is the very high gas prices
are a negative indicator for the economy.
Gas prices coming down are a good thing.
And so we have to analyze these things not
so much in the full depth that you and I might,
but in terms of how it is perceived as far
as a presidency goes and a very good 26 days
for Joe Biden, will it continue?
We don't know, but we will follow it.